at a certain point this insanity needs
to stop and we all sort of need to
realize what it is that's going on which
is that there is a trump Russia story
there's just too much here and it goes
beyond whether you specifically think
there was criminal obstruction of
justice for example what I'm talking
about is a much more overarching theme
and I want to be really clear in in
respect with respect to the defense's
that sometimes people put up it doesn't
mean that Hillary was a good candidate
it doesn't mean that the Democratic
National Committee didn't screw Bernie
Sanders it means only what it is and to
add to this growing list the Trump
administration is now refusing just
straight-up saying they're not going to
do it
refusing to enact new sanctions on
Russia shocking right I'm truly shocked
that Trump is not going to sanction the
one country that he's avoided
criticizing during the last two years
nor has he insulted the leaders of that
country which seems to be a trend for
Trump in most parts of the world these
are the new sanctions that were voted on
and enacted by Congress last year for
both Russia's actions in Crimea and for
Russian election meddling and Donald
Trump doesn't even believe that meddling
took place right he just doesn't believe
it so it does sort of follow logically
based on that harebrained internal logic
that if he doesn't even believe that
there was meddling that he certainly
wouldn't believe that Russia should be
punished for meddling that he claims not
to believe exists but listen to how
absurd this part is the Trump
administration is actually saying they
don't need to do the sanctions because
the threat of at some future point doing
sanctions is enough of a deterrent to
Russia this is the same Trump
administration that goes by the
principles of hit him where it hurts
show him who's boss law and order we're
tough really tough the toughest but when
it comes to Russia they're saying hey
you know we don't need the
actual punishment because just the
threat of some possible punishment in
the future is enough to get him to do
what it is we wanted to do
burglars won't steal again even if you
don't punish them because they know that
if they do it again they might actually
get punished murderers don't need to
actually be tried and imprisoned for the
murders because the fear of a future
indictment would keep them from ever
murdering again this is the logic of the
Trump administration if you believe that
that is a valid explanation for why
Russia shouldn't be sanctioned and it's
completely inconsistent to because after
North Korea was developing their nuclear
weapons capabilities and guesting
ballistic missiles the Trump
administration imposed new sanctions on
North Korea just saying that threatening
them with sanctions was a deterrent
wasn't an argument then and you
shouldn't be now they're only
subscribing to this logic with Russian
sanctions because everywhere else they
seem to say well yeah maybe they want to
do more even more than sanctions but
sanctions are okay it's always Russia
right it's not Peru it's not Papua New
Guinea it's not the Maldives it's yet
again Russia that gets the special
treatment now I want to prepare you for
something else there are two lines that
you're going to hear more and more from
trumpets on this on this non sanctioning
of Russia first will be why don't you
want better relations with Russia
wouldn't wouldn't it be good to have a
better relationship with Russia it's a
red herring okay of course in any
situation we'd rather be friends with
countries than be enemies with countries
or have a hostile situation with
countries but Russia already did things
that Congress determined there should be
sanctions for and now pulling out of
thin air well let's just be friends
everybody should be friends skip the
punishment that is a standard that these
same trumpets aren't applying to other
countries but number two you're also
hearing and and you often you hear it or
read it in the trademark broken English
that is the calling card of the Russian
trolls on the Internet
you hear sanctions don't work they just
hurt the people that's perfectly
legitimate to debate right and we
we can have a reasonable disagreement
over sanctions as a tool but to only
choose to want to debate sanctions when
it's to defend Trump not sanctioning
Russia then you've been co-opted and in
fact speaking of these troll BOTS or
Russian troll protesters they're not all
BOTS they're everywhere online the same
broken English that you see saying the
FISA memo will destroy the Trump Russian
narrative any day now are the same folks
coming out of the woodwork saying thank
you to Donald Trump for bettering the
relations between Russia and the u.s.
they are everywhere and I want to be
clear I'm not saying everyone who posts
this stuff online is a Russian troll but
you can very clearly discern that this
is a movement that exists online we see
it just on our own YouTube posts yeah
and we covered it there are like 30,000
Russian BOTS out there tweeting released
the memo hashed it released the memo has
been a big thing and I know people
always say but David I'm not a Russian
bot and I used the release the memo
hashtag we're not saying it's like all
all squares or rectangles but not all
rectangles or squares that is a hashtag
and a a post being used a lot by Russian
trolls and robots but that doesn't mean
anyone using it is one of those so now
what well we'll have a couple of
Republicans like John McCain and Lindsey
Graham who will say they're deeply
disturbed about the lack of enacting
sanctions but they'll probably not
really do anything about it and then of
course you'll see Donald Trump continue
to just say hey listen there was no
collusion period but continue to try to
displace fire or force the resignations
of anyone who's looking into that that's
the path forward and of course this
isn't direct evidence of Trump Russia
collusion OG it's not even
circumstantial but it's one of those
things that doesn't pass the sniff test
absolutely seen that time and time again
that's why we're having an investigation
no question about it so yet again it's
not Peru it's not the Maldives it's not
Madagascar it's always Russia that seems
to get the preferential special
treatment from or Saudi Arabia we've
also seen but a completely different
reasons in a completely different area
of sort of geopolitical circumstances
the video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program
you can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership